to the extent that i will know myself in
a couple of years and i'm literally tie
myself to another person for instance
with mothers
the mom you would be to your first child
is not the same
the same parenting style you would have
maybe let's say there's a five year age
gap between your next child you wouldn't
be the same mom to your second child
because you've had completely different
life experiences you've learned you've
learned a lot about yourself so how you
would deal with your relationship with
that person would be different that's my
that's my point essentially so do you do
you think do you want to get the best
possible partner that you can get
of course like in terms of like who you
would marry and settle down with
so the point when we talk about getting
married early i'm not saying get married
at 18 right so i think i think there's
some some truth to that like 18 for me
probably be a little too young but what
i'm saying is you're going to have
everything in life's a negotiation right
so if you want to get the best deal you
can younger is better because men prefer
younger women that have lower body
counts and it's not it's not fun i don't
enjoy that like i'm gonna hit 30 and i'm
going to be less valuable to a guy but
it's dishonest for me not to understand
that fact
and so
if you want to get the best quality
partner you can get it's just better to
negotiate when you're younger
okay i do get what you're saying in
terms of that but one thing you said is
the value
that's i feel like that's where i
disagree the most in terms of
the way we see value like what we term
as a valuable woman or as a valuable man
um
in terms of value like
personally for myself i would say value
in a person i wouldn't want someone that
doesn't
you don't even know what you want in
life you don't know who you are which i
feel like the earlier 20s that's a lot
of what it is well that's but that's a
female lens and it's why women don't
pretend to date guys under 25 they tend
to date guys five to seven years older
so again this is like you're seeing
things from a female point of view like
you want a guy with experience you don't
want a guy who doesn't want to have
himself figured out but a guy on the
other hand they want a girl that's gonna
get on their program
okay i would say again i agree with what
you're saying but um
i disagree with the get with your
program like me personally
i've that's the thing i feel like before
women were with the get with the program
but now women have their own program
right that's how i see that's how i see
it and that's why i think makes the
difference
in terms of age well i know and that's
why that's why like honestly modern
women are leftover women because they're
either left over from the last guy or
they're left over in their 30s
because we're not the things that men
value anymore
i think sometimes people confuse what
men actually want
they go with their looks and
men just want somebody to risk to have
their back cook clean and just support
them and
peace is that what you're saying that
men want yeah yeah
i'm telling you that's what men want
they don't care about you know the looks
initial yeah it's like can you cook can
you clean can you look after the kids do
not mean do you know how to organize
money if i give you a hundred pounds a
day can you turn it into 200 pounds
tomorrow
young woman can do that i'm saying any
woman with the right man that is
determined to have a successful
relationship can do that that is what
the men want men don't want you to go
out you know handbags and makeup and
shoes and that save that for a day save
that for christmas
men want a woman to have their back
they want you know that bonnie and clyde
had they rolled together that's how i'm
that's what a man wants and
you might say it was a generation thing
back then it's still now and if you ask
if you ask boys or young men about your
age around your age what they want
they say oh no that's a woman for now
not a woman forever
what's a woman for now the women that
they're having sex with all the young
girls that right now i mean could you
describe a woman for now what for a
young guy yeah anyone you're sleeping
with men don't care you're good looking
you're gonna sleep with them you're a
woman for now
you could be a woman for an hour for two
years you could be a woman for now for
three years they will sleep with the
same one all the time but you're not
gonna get married because you're not a
woman forever i'll describe it i'll
describe it so a woman for now might be
considered someone that believes she's
independent she don't need a man
because as a man like if i'm in a
relationship and i don't feel needed
it's like why am i here
but is that not a young woman would you
not say that that that like the
independent that tends to be a young
woman no no
no no no no that tends to be the modern
woman
most modern women are younger and i
think it's a
i think it's so bad that women can't see
the other side that society's kind of
pushing the narrative that being an
independent is the way to go
establish your career
um
get married later and
you're missing a trick because
what it is is men value fertility and
youth so
your best bet to get the man you want is
to get him between the ages of 21 to 25
because once you look for him older he's
going to be thinking oh i can find you
at a younger age
why would i come for you
so it it's it's a sad truth but that's
just reality but the truth all the
things
yeah i think
the main
like the
the crux of your point i would say rest
on the fertility point like aside from
that
i don't see why a man would want a
younger woman
for a for long term because what you're
saying is because so we're talking about
looks and we're saying that we're
assuming that looks is when you're at
your prime in terms of looks when
between the ages of 21 and 26 and you
said like would that not be a woman for
now that's what i'm saying but if you're
basing it on looks
which you're equating to being young
would that not be a woman for now that's
what i'm saying
so the only other point that you would
go for a young woman is based on
fertility
right because he wants he wants someone
to have kids with yeah that's what i'm
saying that's the only other reason that
you would look for a woman that's young
that's why a lot of girls like the cheat
code is you date guys that are older
because they're more they're looking for
something serious more than guys your
own age yeah that's what yeah but so so
he what he's talking about is the modern
woman mindset where it's me me me me
first
and it's never like i can't compromise
anything in my life for someone else
yeah i would say i disagree that's what
i'm saying
again i don't think we should see as
extremes because marriage is not an
extreme like marriage is based on
compromise
so
in terms of the modern woman i was
again i would say the modern woman is in
is an extreme would you not agree
no i think it's very common i think that
i mean the average age of first marriage
in the uk is 31.
i mean in terms of mindset like in terms
of mindset i would say anyone that waits
till 31 to get married has the modern
woman mindset in some in some regard and
they're getting older
they have some a lot of the older women
that were looking back and thinking i
could be a modern woman at 40 and 45
it's too late for them but again another
thing with this generation is
we have less kids like families are way
smaller in this generation and that's
another reason like it's linked to that
but
the reason why there's less kids is big
there's less kids but there's not less
sex
because back in the day
the more sex you had the more children
you had yeah but now
that's why you only had back in the day
you only had sex with one person because
you're gonna have kids with them but now
there's less kids
there's more sex because there's
contraception and that's what the men
don't want
so you might say you know what they
might want me because i've not had no
children but you might have
no children but 15 previous partners
and that's the difference